me the question is how do you stand out
forever there's a level of practicality
that's different for everyone
predicated on how fancy they want to be
how much money do you need to take home
to pay for your life that you're so
happy about where's your happiness and
where's the things you want that anybody
for where's that Mendoza like then let
me ask you a question do you need four
sports jackets or three do you need
eleven pairs of pants or seven do you
need to go in three vacations or two my
friend every dollar you put back into
your business gives you the potential to
have that business be healthier long
term I believe this entire conference
and this entire space is broken and
everything is based on data that isn't
actually practical to the reality of the
business most people start businesses to
take the money out to buy themselves
things which is why they never build
long-term big business
you understand there's a fundamental
reason I have the career that I have the
only thing I have is energy for the long
term when you can oversell your reality
but then build to the new reality that's
how you get big for Boehner media I was
able to over the last five years grow us
from 22 people to 800 people from 3
million to a hundred million in revenue
because I can continue to do my model
we're gonna make less money this year
and a hundred million that we made last
year at 67 net I don't mean percentage
net historically I'd like to run them
where one year is profitable in the next
year is not so the growth is there both
the non profitable other every other
year was predicated on me being able to
invest in people advertising the
resources more people more capabilities
because I'm gonna take the whole [ __ ]
pie
99% the marquetry and the 1% that isn't
and has the talent wins every time
which makes no sense because unless
you're gonna die
you should only play long if you're
gonna live to be in 2020 you might as
well play to be in 2020 the
disproportionate reason that most people
in this room will not win is actually
not the hard work which is what I'm
going to talk about probably for the
next 45 minutes it's your lack of
patience today with all the things that
have happened to me I get emails on
Facebook from friends I went to high
school with often starting with Gary
you're so lucky
I reply to every single one of them all
of them with the reply of an opening
line first Jan great to see you again
you look great kids super cute PS I am
super not lucky let me remind you Rick
remember when we graduated college and
you went to the Jersey Shore every
weekend and hooked up with chicks and
drank beer I worked you know it when I
was 22 to 28 I was making thirty five to
fifty five thousand dollars a year but I
had no expenses I didn't go on vacations
I didn't buy fancy things so I saved my
money I saved my money I saved my money
and then when the till you know I had
hundreds of thousands of dollars I
didn't have millions I had hundreds of
thousands of dollars because I didn't
spend anything and and then I started
making $100,000 a year in 150 thousand a
year and by the time I was 33 34 when I
had that opportunity I still not bought
a home I was still in an apartment I was
33 years old and I was renting and
because I was saving cash to go on the
offense and I knew something would
happen one day and hid and so when I had
a chance to invest in those companies
I put hundreds of thousands of dollars
not millions but those hundreds made
millions made tens of millions and so
that's it nothing crazy nothing I didn't
have any crazy crazy advantage there's a
lot of people that make fifty five
thousand dollars a year when they're 23
the problem is they go to Coachella and
they want to buy a watch and they want
to buy a BMW
and I didn't so I ate [ __ ] for 13 years
and then I had a moment and I struck out
he won I figured myself out I know what
makes me happy
nothing in the world makes me happier
than being able to know and by the way
this is for everybody everybody is the
happiest when they get to do what they
want to be doing when you get to do what
you want to do you've won
that is the seductive nature of
entrepreneurship because you have
control there's no boss but the company
can become your boss the stuff
overextending yourself and paying for
your lifestyle can become your boss not
paying attention to what makes you happy
anymore can become your boss and that's
why I try to stay grounded and that
stuff I am stunningly the most rational
and the most practical of all yet I
don't see them the only way to stand out
in my opinion is to stand out for the
long term you could do a lot of things
to stand out for the next week you can
use shock movement you can growth hack
you can buy follow it all the dumb [ __ ]
that everybody's doing to win for a week
or a month maybe even a year to me the
question is how do you stand out forever
[Music]